he's allowed to use all means possible
legally speaking to try to find a way to
fight the outcome hey guys I'm off the
grid for August but Donald Trump never
takes any time off and here's his latest
Congressman have you spoken with
President Trump since this latest
indictment and it's if so what are you
hearing from him
um so actually we haven't talked uh I
sent him a text message about something
uh slightly different I mean look the
president's a fighter he's not going to
stand for this and no American should
because what this is from Jack Smith is
a complete violation of an individual's
First Amendment rights you're allowed to
speak about elections and the outcomes
even if big media and the radical left
don't like it you're allowed to say it
secondarily because he was the candidate
in that election he's allowed to use all
means possible legally speaking to try
to find a way to fight the outcome he's
allowed to do that nobody can take that
away from you especially some Rogue
knucklehead prosecutor out of the
Department of Justice foreign